today's meeting was remarkable in the
sense that it was an unprecedented
signal of trust unity and consensus of
the 27 and I feel that this is a very
good start to these complex negotiations
ahead of us
these guidelines define the overall
framework and are the basis for
negotiating directives under article 50
all delegations agreed with the overall
trust of the guidelines and express
their full support the main elements of
the guidelines were achieving a fair and
equitable result for all member states
and maintaining unity and trust within
the 27 the core principles remain the
same basically as the original draft
integrity of the single markets
balance of rights and obligations note
sector negotiations a single package and
a single channel of communication the
phased approach will provide orderly
with royal as well as clarity and legal
certainty he priority at this stage and
which were mentioned by practically all
member states are issues pertaining to
citizens rights the financial settlement
and border methods following the
adoption of the guidelines this Saturday
the council will proceed with the
adoption of the decision authorizing the
opening of the negotiations it is clear
that brexit will have an impact on many
important files and issues as a
presidency however we are determined not
to let the significant and complex issue
to derail us from the Union strategic
agenda and other legislative files